Speaker 1: OK.
The U.S. Army, after giving so much notice
and giving every opportunity for service members
to go and get themselves vaccinated with the
COVID vaccine is at the end of the grace period,
and the U.S. Army is going to start discharging
COVID vaccine refusers effective immediately.
NPR reporting.
U.S. Army soldiers who refused to be vaccinated
for COVID will soon be discharged.
The military branch announced yesterday Wednesday.
The army said it will quote immediately begin
separating soldiers from the service who refused
to be vaccinated or who don't have an approved
or pending request for exemption.
Secretary of the Army Christine Warmth said
army readiness readiness depends on soldiers
who are prepared to train, deploy, fight and
win our nation's wars.
Unvaccinated soldiers present risk to the
force and jeopardize readiness.
Soldiers who are discharged for refusing to
be vaccinated quote will not be eligible for
involuntary separation pay and may even have
to return unearned, special or incentive pay.
Now the right is framing this as we are dramatically
weakening.
I don't know why I'm doing the Alex Jones
voice.
We are dramatically weakening the military
and we are going to be more battle rather
than alpha in fighting wars, which they claim
they don't want to fight anyway.
But as of January 26th, as the article points
out, 96 percent of active duty troops were
completely vaccinated.
Thirty three hundred soldiers have refused.
Fifty nine hundred have temporary exemptions,
and those are temporary in the sense that
their requests are still being reviewed.
This is really not a big deal.
It's time you need a bunch of vaccines to
be in the military.
This is the latest vaccine you need.
It's not controversial.
We've gone through the list.
I'm not going to do it again.
Is it 10 15?
Depending on where you're serving, it can
be closer to 20 different vaccines that you
have to get when you're in the military.
If you won't follow a simple service wide
vaccine mandate that is like the 13th or the
18th or whatever, it's not unique.
It's not.
We've never had any vaccine requirements.
And now here's one you've got to get.
They all got in line for all the other vaccines
when they enlisted.
It's just time to say you're not fit for military
service.
Oh, I'm not taking this one vaccine because
of my rights or my religion or.
Come on, guys, come on.
Now one thing that I heard from some service
members about and I did a little research
into this and it does appear to be true, is
a.
Bill was passed taking dishonorable discharge
is off the table for vaccine refusers.
So what I'm hearing from some of our viewers
who are in the military is that there are
people who have been sort of wanting to get
out for a little while and they're taking
this as an opportunity.
Now again, we're only talking about 3300 unvaccinated
with no exemption right now.
So it's like a tiny, tiny percentage of individuals
and some fraction of those maybe refusing
the vaccine, not because they're actually
against it, but because they want a way to
get out without a dishonorable discharge.
So that may be a factor to some degree, but
I don't think it's a dominant thing.
But anecdotally, it does seem to exist from
what I'm hearing, but there's really nothing
controversial here.
It is not going to affect overall military
readiness.
It's not going to affect in any material way
the massive fighting force that the United
States has.
And it really shouldn't even be getting the
attention that it's getting because it's not
never needed vaccines.
And now you do.
Like I said, it's you always needed 12 to
13 or but depending on where you're serving,
you needed 17 now you need 18.
It's not a big deal and it shouldn't be made
into one.
And the military has been saying for a long
time, this is exactly what we're going to
do.
And now they're doing it.
It would be more of a problem, I would argue,
if they said that this is what they were going
to do and then they failed to do it.
They promised this was the path and they're
doing it, and it makes perfect sense.
If you disagree with me, let me know you can
find me on Twitter at Packman.
We're going to take a very short break.
We really have a fantastic program for you
today.
Remember that the David Pakman show does depend
on viewers and listeners like you to support
what we do every day, including our new thing,
sending correspondents to Trump rallies and
other political events to interview people,
which I'll talk more about in a moment.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
Members get instant access to the bonus show
and the bonus show.
You know, for years I've been telling you
the bonus show is world-famous, which is true.
The bonus show is award winning, which is
true.
We give out the awards, but they still our
awards.
But now I can tell you and and accurately
tell you this is the bonus show brutally attacked
by conspiracy theorist Alex Jones.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad, right?
Speaker 1: I can think of no greater endorsement
for the bonus show than the fact that Alex
Jones has attacked it.
And you can sign up at join Packman dot com
coupon code.
Newt Remember Alex Jones called me a predator?
New coupon code is Predator 22.
OK, Predator 22 saves you big bucks off of
the bonus show at Join Pacman dot com!